and the importance of andrew heaney
pushing through to seven innings was not
lost on joe madden or andrew heaney yeah
he said he was very competitive he liked
the way he went out and competed that
last game out there he had good stuff
working he said that's the type of
picture he can be this is down the left
field line that'll drop a base hit and
heading towards second testing the arm
of upton is rival and he's got a leg
double wonderful start brendan rodgers
will be the next hitter
got him
heaney
with a breaking ball and there is out
number one the angels would love to get
seven more innings out of andrew heaney
tonight one out here story it's a short
lead for toppy at third the 3-2 is well
hit the left field upton's just gonna
watch it fly
touch him all time for trevor story
number 13 and the rockies take a two to
nothing lead that was a line shot
came off the bat at 107 miles an hour
there's another good swing there that's
five swinging misses on this curveball
three punch outs but two runs the
rockies with a two run homer and lucas
gilbreth will make it a bullpen game he
gets the first of what will be many
pitchers out there
he is the opener and here comes ohtani
hot smash into right field that's a base
hit
that's a product of it in field of
trying to get to the baseball already
think about what type of throw and how
he's going to be able to get that ball
out of his glove quickly and roger is
unable to look it into the glove because
of the speed and the angels have
something going here with otani at
second gosling at first now upton
and looks like justin upton's gonna
break another bat over his leg
hillyard makes the catch two outs jose
iglesias will be in the next matter
into left field a base hit atani flying
around third topping up with the ball
throw to the plate is off
and the angels were on the board
here that is clutch iglesias coming
through 30-second rbi
tapia with a good throwing arm six
outfield assist michelle hey otani
running
taking that shot on him and scoring the
first run of this inning here for the
angels bases loaded two outs so eaton
will step up he could give the angels a
lead here
he drives it into center field but right
there to grab it garrett hampson
it wasn't easy but lucas gilbreth allows
just one run four strikeouts already for
andrew heaty has a walk rogers now
[Applause]
trevor story the home run to left his
13th and here's the next pitch and
there's a swing and a miss a fastball
thrown past story elevated fastball
struck him out so heeney has a clean
inning and he's also
retired the last six batters in a row
first batter up will be shohei ohtani
santos working in his second inning
delivers and that is high and outside
nowhere close and ohtani has a lead-off
walk so he's on phil gosling will be the
battery and the pitch is a breaking ball
pulled to the left side cutting in front
is mcmahon and he flips the ball over to
rogers to get the force on ohtani now
iglesias who's been a really dependable
hitter in the last few weeks
is that playable i hope so it is diaz
found a baseball made the catch
and iglesias is the second out
2-1 pitch hit in the air by stassi right
field coming in is hilliard he makes the
catch and antonio santos works out of it
the third inning out of four that the
rockies have the lead off man on brian
mcmahon
this is slice to left base hit
diaz gonna try to stretch it to third on
update
safe
and mcmahon followed suit
second and third
this may have caught justin upton by
surprise he's gonna have to pitch around
trouble here lead off walk and a double
oh
got him 92
and he rode that four seamer it's a big
out he still has two more to get sam
hilliard will be the next batter
kicks away from alma diaz is gonna slide
home
how about the base running for elias
diaz three to one colorado mcmahon the
third well he's aggressive because again
with one out and infield drawn in it's a
contact play well the aggressive base
running pays off twice in this inning
mayfield line one to center fletcher is
hit suddenly ohtani is up with runners
first and second oh
right field a bullet
and down
three run shot
37 and the angels grabbed the lead
for it and the fans were going nuts here
that's why they came to the ballpark to
see something special and show hay did
it again three-run home run home run
number 37 just like that the halos are
up with shohei two out single keeping
the inning alive and justin upton will
be the next batter
up to left field and
gone two run homer the lead gets bigger
and that's a big moment for justin upton
looking for his grooves that's coming
off the il looking to see that uptown
funk
turns on it blinds it out he walks
trevor on four pitches and now the
rockies are a swing away from tying it
with elias diaz coming up the 2-2 it's
on its way he struck him out swinging
that's how the inning ends and he gets
number eight max stasi will lead it off
for the angels here in the bottom of the
fifth stassey
left center
it's deep
it is gone
man max
man is he hot ninth of the season he's
always here to entertain us maximus rich
that's power ben bowden is the new arm
for the rockies so the first batter up
for the angels will be shohei ohtani
who's having a nice night they haven't
retired him there is strike three called
on a fastball at the knees good pitch by
ben bowden yeah tommy walks away just
sort of indicating that not sure he was
expecting that kind of pitch
here they are two on down four nobody
out top of the order
this ball is hit pretty well to center
field and deep and
it is off the very top of the wall
coming home is fuentes
and trailing him is hampton and garrett
will score two run double here come the
rockies rival topia to dead center two
on that'll bring up elias diaz
this ball hit hard oh great play by
mayfield there's one
and
runs it's to score tapia makes it a
one-run game
phil gosselin could not handle the throw
from fletcher if he does it's an inning
ending double play
instead
the rockies are within a run watson in
relief of seashell first and second two
outs and two straight delivery there's a
swing and a miss and he got him on a
change-up after all of that broke him
out and that is how the inning will end
rockies are drawn within one two outs
iglesias has one out here in the eight
yeah this ball bounced over the head of
the first baseman into right field
gosselin and fuentes to third 90 feet
away rymel with a four hit ball game so
brendan rogers will see what he can do
this ball pulled through the whole base
hit
tie ball game brandon rogers coming
through seven up banana
fletcher's 90 feet away then a big at
bat for gosling line drive base head
left field
here comes fletcher
gosling delivers the goose
is losing rbi go ahead
pick for phil gosling now iglesias and
has connor joe
slow roller iglesias has it flips ball
game angels win the series back over
500.